We can't afford just to tinker around the
edges,
a tax credit here, a regulation there,
our fight is for big structural change.
Elizabeth Warren wants the federal government
to provide free healthcare for every American,
college for every student who wants it,
childcare for every parent,
and housing for low income families.
And she wants to pay for it all with a new
tax on the richest of the rich.
She calls it the Ultra-Millionaire Tax.
Skimming a bit more off the top of the bank
accounts of the ultra wealthy
might sound like a good deal for working and
middle class Americans
who feel like they're falling behind.
But the reality is that wealth taxes have
been tried before
and they haven't worked the way that Warren
promises.
Here's why:
Warren wants to levy a 2% annual wealth tax
on all households with a net worth of over
50 million dollars
and a 3% annual tax on those households with
net worths over one billion dollars.
All I'm asking for is a little slice from
the tippy tippy top.
A 2 or 3 percent tax on multi millionaires
and billionaires might not sound like much.
They got to pitch in two cents and two cents
on every dollar after that.
Wealth taxes are different than other taxes
like, say, an income tax or a sales tax
which tax money when it moves around.
A wealth tax on the other hand taxes the same
pot of money every year.
Meaning that over time it becomes smaller
and smaller.
It's essentially a tax on large savings,
the money that investors and entrepreneurs
rely on to start new businesses.
But I do think a system that allows billionaires
to exist
when there are parts of Alabama where people
are still getting ringworm
because they don't have access to public health,
is wrong.
Unlike Alexandria Ocasio Cortez,
Warren has never said that the existence of billionaires is immoral
but her plan to tax two to three percent of
their wealth on an annual basis
is clearly motivated at least in part by a
desire to reduce their wealth
and what she perceives as a power imbalance
in our society.
The economists who helped Warren design her
plan
have said that the idea is to make rich people
less wealthy.
In analyzing her plan, they wrote that:
It's not really about raising tax revenue,
it's about using government power to make
sure rich people have less.
-that much wealth is bad for our economy and
bad for our democracy.
Warren has often pitched her plan as a way
to raise money from the ultra rich
to pay for more government benefits for everyone
else.
And on that count, it's likely to fall short.
Warren says her tax plan will raise 2.75 trillion
dollars over a ten year period.
But other countries have tried wealth taxes
and found that they raise far less money than
expected.
In 1990, there were twelve OECD nations with
wealth taxes similar to Warren's.
Today only four remain.
In Scandinavia of course healthcare is a right,
higher education is free.
Despite the tendency of politicians like Bernie
Sanders to hold up Denmark and Sweden
as paragons of Democratic Socialism that the
US should emulate,
the reality is that both nixed their wealth
taxes in the 1990s
because too many rich citizens were pulling
their money out of the country.
This capital flight resulted in lower rates
of entrepreneurship
and relative economic stagnation.
Not only did the wealth tax hurt the economy,
it didn't even raise the money it was supposed
to.
When Sweden eliminated it's wealth tax
it had virtually no effect on government finances.
France tried a wealth tax for more than a
decade starting in 2000.
It helped push an estimated 42000 millionaires
out of the country.
They didn't pay the tax, they just left.
What Warren wants to get around the capital flight
problem
by taxing the money no matter where in the
world it's located.
And imposing a 40% exit tax on anyone who
wants to renounce his or her citizenship.
We're going to be out there countin' them
and watching them.
What we built right into the plan was far
more sophisticated
and more investment in the enforcement.
Warren's plan relies on hiring more IRS agents
partly to deal with the complexity of evaluating
total individual wealth.
But throwing more tax collectors at the problem
isn't going to change the fact
that the wealthy are very good at protecting
their money.
By offshoring it or by putting it into unique,
hard to value assets like artwork.
Austria is one of the countries that used
to have a wealth tax.
One of the reasons the country ended it was
because the cost of enforcement was so high.
Based on it's failure in other countries
and her vague proposals for addressing those
failures,
there's no compelling evidence that Warren's
Ultra Millionaire Tax
will raise the revenue she claims.
The wealth tax is best understood not as a
targeted revenue raiser
but as a symbolic declaration of opposition
to the existence of out sized wealth
regardless of how it was obtained.
What I want is I want these billionaires to
stop being freeloaders.
Warren has described the Ultra Millionaire
Tax as a tool for addressing inequality.
But really it's just a presidential candidate's
way of saying
'I oppose the existence of very rich people'
She could have just said it.